- What was it like reading
the series finale script?
(gentle ambient music)
(letters clacking)
- I don't know if there's a word
or even phrase that can sum it up.
- It was like, "What the fuck?"
- My mom's gonna lose her mind.
- I was shocked, scared for a lot of it.
- I think the fans are gonna love it.
- It's heartwarming, a little dangerous.
- It's a big episode.
- It's a rollercoaster.
- A redemption for the
characters in the story.
- There are deaths, there's heartache.
- It's a crazy episode.
Angelina gets her just desserts.
- I have a lot to tell you.
- But there's also tons of joy.
- I don't think fans will
be disappointed at all.
But for us as actors, it
was severely emotional.
I mean, we're saying goodbye to characters
that we've held dear for so long.
- That almost destroyed me.
- I mean, this has been almost
five years of our lives.
- I can't believe that this is the end.
- I think it's the right
ending for these characters.
And I cried a lot.
- We've had most of the bones
of the finale in our head
from the very beginning.
To finally put it on paper
was incredibly cathartic.
The good people live, the bad people die,
and everybody gets a do over.
- It just feels right, so
when you're reading it,
it doesn't feel like, "Wait, what?"
It kind of feels like, "Of course."
- I don't think I was surprised,
I was more of just like,
"Yeah, it makes sense."
- [Director] And action!
- We actually just finished
shooting a lot of it,
and so going through
the acting aspect of it,
it just felt peaceful, it just felt right,
like a proper goodbye.
- Catharsis, like a journey has completed.
- But I don't wanna say goodbye.
Why do I have to say goodbye?
- It's like a journey has ended,
but a new one is just starting.
- Hmm, nice.
- Oh my God.
In Gupta's lab,
they were tracking underwater
volcanoes across the globe.
They had no way of tracking
subterranean volcanoes
that would arise on land.
- You know, I play a scientist,
so all the science stuff,
it can get very dense.
- What's that line that you
have to say, "To procure-"
- Failed to procure a preferred grade
used commercial sapphire.
- We're all gonna get that tattooed
on our bodies at some point.
- Absolutely, yes.
- I was like, a little nervous
to shoot this final episode,
because my character explodes.
And when I was reading this script,
it says like, all the
other characters explode,
and as I was reading it,
I was like, "Thank God that's not me,"
and then it got to
Angelina and it was like,
"Angelina starts cracking and exploding
"worse than all the others."
And I was like, "God damn it."
Like, I also was just like, a little sad.
I knew it was gonna be over.
So yeah, it was a tough episode to shoot,
but I think very worth it.
- I had a blast, 'cause in my real life,
I have zero authority, you know?
And I've always wanted to play a character
who I get to get out of
a car, slam the door,
and say something definitive
and then people follow me.
- I don't need to tell
you that's impossible.
- I did know after episode
10 that I would be back.
I had lunch with Jeff back
in November of last year
before we started shooting season four.
And he told me about everything,
because at the end of the first block,
we know what happens to Zeke.
But I knew that there would be a way
for Zeke to continue to be in the show
and to play an important role in it.
And so I love the stuff that
I've had in season four.
It feels like a little bit of a return
to season one and two for Zeke,
which was like a dream come true for me.
So yes, I knew.
- I think they did a beautiful job
at bringing it all together.
- Cal.
- How'd you know my name?
- [Actor] You see a lot of
familiar people in this episode.
- We see characters
from the very beginning
and we all come back together.
- A lot of our storylines
don't always overlap,
and so that's always fun
when the whole cast is in,
because it's like a party.
- It was like going to some kind
of strange high school reunion
where you see all these
people from your past.
- A lot of giggles, a lot of crying,
a lot of, "I don't wanna
do this right now."
- So to have us all together
again was, it was a lot of fun.
- Michaela and I? We're
meant to be together.
- Maybe, maybe not.
- All these things that
have been talked about
and planted in stories
that have maybe gone away
are now coming back,
and that is a huge payoff for the fans.
The fans of Zekaela, obviously,
we have these two factions
of really passionate people,
but I think the finale really
does service both groups.
- A hundred percent.
- And I hope that it really touches them.
- One of the biggest, if not
the biggest disappointments
when we were canceled
was to not be able to finish
the story for the fans.
That was a punch in the gut.
And so when we were saved by Netflix
and to be able to share that-
- I think we might have
just saved the world.
- We're coming back, we're
gonna finish the story,
that was incredibly gratifying.
- Thank you to Netflix.
We now globally have a humongous audience
that are gonna be able
to enjoy this journey
because we now have this platform
to release all of four seasons.
And this journey is ending,
but for a lot of people,
the journey is just beginning with Netflix
and being able to join us
on this "Manifest" ride.
- Yeah.
(dramatic music)